[Music]
dear evan hansen is a musical love
letter to all those who feel alone have
you been doing those letters to yourself
with dr sherman i've been trying to dear
evan hansen
today is going to be an amazing day
and here's why
[Music]
because today all you have to do is just
be yourself
[Music]
but also confident that's that's
important and interesting easy to talk
to approachable but mostly just be
yourself you know that's number one
obviously be yourself but like a
confident version of yourself
i've learned to slam on the brake
before i even turn the key before i make
the mistake
before i lead with the worst of me
give them no reason it's there
no slipping up if you slip away
so i got nothing to share
no i got nothing to say
would you want to sign my cast because
we're friends we're family friends evan
would anyone even notice if i just
disappear tomorrow
sincerely our best and most dearest
friend me um no one signed your cast
now we can both pretend we have friends
uh dear evan hansen
yeah yeah that's mine i'll i'll just
take it wait i really i need that back
please don't show it to anyone on the
outside always looking in will i ever be
more than i've always been cause i'm tap
tap tapping on the glass
i'm waiting through a window
i
try to speak upon nobody can
[Music]
connor took a letter from me and it was
an assignment for my therapist still
connor murphy's mother and stepfather
here to see connor wanted you to have
this
dear evan hansen he wrote it to you his
last words conor took his own life hey
what
i'm sorry connor didn't write this no no
no please we didn't think conor had any
friends
[Music]
and you really going to tell these
people that the only thing they have
left of their son is a letter that you
wrote to yourself so you and connor tell
us something please heaven right um i
started talking and you couldn't stop
they didn't want me to stop i'm putting
together a memorial service if you
wanted to do something
then there's nobody around connor showed
me that i wasn't alone nobody is i wish
we could have given that to you
[Music]
people started sharing it it's
everywhere i don't understand what
happened
it's like i never made a sound will i
ever make a sound
a lot of people feel like us people that
you wouldn't think you don't know how
much you've given my family and me
i never thought that it would go this
far i was trying to help
[Music]
you who i am can anybody see just a
health broken land
i already know you and i love you
i have to tell them
[Music]
you